سياسيا اعرب وزير وخارجيه جيبوتي محمود
علي يوسف عن قلق بلاده من اتساع رقعه
المواجهات وفشل الهدن في السودان وقال
محمود يوسف في مؤتمر صحفي اعقده بالعاصمه
جيبوتي ان سقوط الدوله في السودان ستكون
له عواقب وخيمه على القرن الافريقيه
باكملها ودعا طرفي الصراع الى فتح قنوات
التواصل لتجنيب السودان الانهيار
جميع المؤشرات
توحي الى ان الوضع في السودان
في غايه الخطوره بمعنى انه اجلاء
الدبلوماسيين
واغلاق البعثات الدبلوماسيه هي ربما تكون
الخطوه المرحله التي تؤشر الى صعوبه الوضع
السودان بلد كبير هو تقريبا يعتبر القلب
النابض للقاره الافريقيه وله حدود مع
ثمانيه دول اي انتكاسه اي يعني انهيار
للدوله في السودان
سيكون له انعكاسات خطيره للقاره باكملها